Netflix is becoming the way so many
people experience television and we're
glad cuz the travel shows they've been
putting them on Netflix which is we're
happy about fun Without Borders on
Netflix little plug well recently just
because I've been checking out Netflix
more and more I've noticed this Netflix
has been making shows aimed at older
viewers shows like Grace and Frankie and
the Kaminski method those are just aimed
at an older you know audience and it's
kind of cool because check this out
apparently those shows geared towards
the elderly audiences are doing really
well people like him I think that's nice
it's meeting a good thing it's a good
thing so anyway Netflix notice this they
just announced a whole new lineup of
shows for older viewers for example a
chef's table soft food edition was
coming out there's a comedians on
scooters getting prescription blood
thinners there's the good place that
place where all my friends are
no what is it gonna be no you can't have
it both ways you can't react in horror
and then I'll bet and finally get this a
large print subtitles version of their
show narcos this is going to be a good
night a success from his friends
[Applause]